[Music]
the Oliver choke on cheese on pizza yeah
and you're not ready to ring the alarm
yet you're not ready to tell anyone
you're just like hold let me see how far
this goes oh yeah yeah yeah
noodles you know the crazy one it's like
it's so true and you're like just
putting it deeper you're like is it
gonna end soon or am I gonna die first
do you get this vehicle to get this
where you like eat too fast so it gets
like stuck and you can't breathe yeah
yes 100 yeah yeah
new appreciation for life
[Laughter]
I gotta check this one
I used to get that like Elena and I
would smoke and then I would eat too
fast so then I'd be high and then I'm
thinking I'm dying too so that you know
she's sitting there watching the movie
eating and then I'm just like
oh my God
it's the best the best is I'll get it
and I'll sit there and Kelsey's like
why'd you stop because normally I don't
stop I don't stop put everything you're
not sitting there
and she's like drink some water and I
drink water and just lands on top and
I'm like that made it worse
it just goes on top
and it is here yeah I'm like I just have
to wait you're just sliding off the
couch a little bit
laughs
hit the Apple watch SOS
actually make he gets it really bad too
but he'll actually make a sound he'll go
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not even like I don't even know
what it is that he's doing
it's so funny just loading man you just
gotta wait there man that's [__]
painful man Lena's like seeing me go
through it so many times that now she
she looks at me like uh you know like
when your dog can't breathe right that's
how she looks at me yeah you know when
you're like just breathe through your
nose I'll be there like
and she'll be like
why'd you eat all that rice
[Laughter]
no I'm going through something right now
she's just pushing me on my stomach
lifting up my legs like
about
it
[Laughter]
your dog's looking at you
what the [__] is wrong with this it's
pretty [__]
dude it's kind of dangerous to eat alone
huh
oh that's yeah that's
yeah I've gotten close to having one of
those alone but I slowed down but that's
a scary ass feeling you need like a back
stretcher machine man yeah yeah
[Laughter]
don't stand your wife gets home
don't use the stretcher
that [__] sound yeah that just came
up
can we use that as a sound bite please
oh
[Music]
I remember one time I was choking
and it kind of got to that level where
I'm like all right I need attention
you're just not leaving me
I remember they're trying to help me but
you're supposed to you know slap their
back or whatever this person saw him in
the back of my head I'm like yeah
I didn't know if it was right or wrong
I've never choked before so I'm like all
right
yeah keep going some dude think the
Heimlich Maneuvers just knocking
somebody out
damn so what ended up happening no I got
it out you toughed it out yeah yeah and
I had to [__] so much tears in my eyes
and I felt embarrassed yeah paid for a
check and left yeah she's good
eyes yeah there's a french onion soup
see Michigan star
[Music]
as a kid
no I was just choking on chips man uh I
was like chip kid you choke on candy
yeah as a kid no never bro I had one it
was like one of those you know it was
like the stupid like brandless round
candies you get like a restaurant
um
I had one and then uh I like perfectly
like like
right yeah yeah exactly
but bro I don't know like dude I think
but someone tosses you a piece of like
like a smarty or something like that
like I got it
I'm so scared of grapes yeah not my game
I
don't know
a lot of shrimp yeah
[Laughter]
slap his head
put your face on the grill
chef chef
turn up the heat and get the shrimp out
yeah before I get out of here I gotta
say my boy got a smarty stuck in his ear
perfectly perfectly in his ear really
yeah it was the perfect like a Canadian
Smartie yeah I gotta get different
shapes
really stuck in his ear
three-day emergency really [__] yeah I'm
being serious man was he just being
funny yeah he was a kid he's just being
stupid and [__] put a smirk
perfectly he's just like every time you
dig it out it's going deeper oh my God
10 seconds yeah just melt my [__]
someone just pulled their airpod out of
there like listening to that like right
now
the rest of this episode on speakers I
don't [__] with that
I survived
because I think when I did that it felt
like enough air like compressed that I
was able to just pretty immediately like
immediately like just [__] cool and
it yeah
you just get humbled yeah yeah yeah
almost died
like you almost died but not not really
no my mom just turned around she was
like what the [__] bro I'm like sorry
sorry I'm learning yeah no more
experiences I'm sorry
dog yeah those candies are uh are
[__] dangerous so I forgot what that
Canadian Candy's called the Tanisha was
choked on
and I say I can't remember it uh yeah it
was like caramel but there's also orange
in the Cherry it was like a swirl but it
was like cream you guys should remember
this it was like big candy it was a
cream cream it was creamy but it was
like
um
same thing Circle yeah that sounds good
it's really crazy that like Werther's
Originals are associated with old people
because you know what I'm talking about
yeah yeah that's it yeah it's wild that
old person is known for that because I
feel like as an old person that's
dangerous yeah yes but again yeah yeah
yeah
foreign